all right hid we are laughs Happy Easter
welcome to the iron Lord vodcasts and
the Lords of gaming dotnet episode
number 107 and it's another glorious
Sunday we're back at the roundtable on
the Lord's Day and we've got halo
infinite battle royal PlayStation 5 spec
review inside Xbox switch mini and
switch Pro Plus do Jeon Capcom console
to discuss so we go get right into it so
let's introduce the four horsemen of
gaming those original Lords of the realm
here at the round table
my co-host with the cold most my brother
from another mother the difficult game
Conqueror and the house of the young
wolf mommy
Lord addict how you doing sir doing
pretty good getting getting stomped in
Sakura over and over again beat me
people do not disturb me do not disturb
me because I was like I saw him warm and
I saw him playing Seconal that's like
don't disturb me you a little to your
madness addict we're gonna get this last
boss candle man maybe this time next
year oh just so to be on a second role
100% that's what it's been yeah 100% and
of course I gotta give something new
knee server control the similar game of
list for the single player selfish
experience and also the samus Jaffe
joffrey profile loominatee and Lord
patreon of the iron bank mom
louis cyphre how you doing sir I am
extra fantastic today because I'm not
hosted go when I click the link
everything is good everybody knows just
to play losing out the two levels goes
that crazy like we had this issue with
Omni boxes maybe two last words ago and
it just happened with he's debuting and
we ever able to resolve but yeah that's
Google Hangouts changing policy don't
worry about us ah what's going on glad
to see you back glad to see you
energetic man doing good man doing good
do get down know that what you've been
playing Nathan it's been a good two to
three weeks I've done nothing I was just
telling our attic that I haven't since
our PAX East I haven't gone any further
in suck yo which is killing me I haven't
played anything I did pick up I just
picked up the cup headed for the switch
just to support I wanted to support that
game I may not ever have turned it on
but I just want to make sure they get
that online co-op that was supposed to
remember they always say that was gonna
be an additional feature and we may
never know wait this couch co-op and a
game in an online co-op now still not on
the Xbox version Elise I don't know
check around if I'm wrong Lords of the
realm if you guys know anything that I
don't but as far as I remember
they never added it they said they were
going to it was a feature that they said
they will look into it did they add the
extra character to remember the female
character right with the DLC that's
supposed to be here it'd be crazy if
they had Mariota so I came in he got
this rotate this you're understand we
means like you can't keep that anywhere
like really yeah but that statues of for
sale for five thousand so that makes
sense yeah yeah I got this Taylor's
coming up this week interesting Kos
so as avenges and game come out this
week so you know our something else I
really have another statue that's back
there that's sill bully but I have to do
this statue in for endgame so that says
nope this with you see no yeah so being
a we already kind of intro you gonna
show me again and of course we have the
Incredible Hulk of this aka the XS game
ooh
the lord of combat sports was a man of
his convictions demands nothing less
than that premium experience it is the
leader of the fraud alert movement ooh
beloved Lord King how you doing sir I'm
doing fantastic holdover combat so let's
get out there after better need to my
man Super G all over on but and you know
I'm not to say I wasn't all over but but
isn't my top 5 Dead Alive you understand
but the problem is I thought this was
right for the picking I thought you know
boat was definitely gonna either take a
dive left by not respecting Khan's
skill and he like I said he jumped on
gone early he stayed in pocket work on
he didn't allow
to do his game plan but remember when
the low blow happened was in a six-round
so that's half we passed a fight you
understand mm-hmm
I'm not saying that pecan wasn't taking
a beating throughout the fight you know
he was giving he was taking some
movements but he didn't have dominant
moments like he needed to have in order
to beat bud so remember the low blow
came I'm not saying that you know he
conceded but he you know in a rut was
out you know form a combat talk but I
did watch one thing
did you see Teddy Alice's analysis Teddy
Atlas is a strong word but I hate her I
want y'all to take this part I want
somebody to send this to tell you I tell
you no Teddy it's not about you
everything's a spectacle to you you know
um your husband to keep living off of
other people's name you knew they shut
you down at ESPN before because she's
motivating a lion so now they got you
over there with Stephen a Smith to get
you a little bit more respectability
back into the game bro just stitch
yourself down nor has he ever been any
of those words that you chose to use as
that Olympian that Olympian for who and
what he has done that man has done
numerous things inside the game and he
has always pushed the envelope he did
not have to fight but he could have went
and fought somebody else made more money
and wanted to fight he fought bud
because he wanted to challenge yourself
everybody in this room knew he wasn't on
beat but I gave him a sliver of hope
hopefully that he can establish his jab
and shoot his right hand over it so
maybe you are absolute fraud you are
disgusting to the game boxing everything
you do about boxing is disrespectful
boxes you make it about yourself and you
have not thrown a punch in the last 70
years
and be quite Debbie go see her before
you go I don't know how you feel about
Teddy Kelly we know how you feel about
Teddy well what question he said Teddy
said that the way to cuffs is designed
that back in the day they demonstrated
it and they hit people with it God was
looking for I was no listen I'm not
gonna say that Khan didn't take the
gimme okay he took - gimme no he took
the game really was ready but he fought
he fought well if he could appear to
that point right before valiantly listen
that man was brutally knocked out is the
last fight and I saw remnants of that in
this fight you don't know how you gonna
come away from beat I mean he was
separated from consciousness no Canelo
hit him with such a shot dead I mean
this make I don't know how many times
this man can get severely knocked out
like that what I'll even hit the ghost
of his body in the ring so after you
become a different fighter you know do I
really need to go this way and talk I
didn't know the history prior is
basically got his roy legs twisty oh
yeah he was okay so from that point the
metallic change as a result of that loss
to Canelo like he a lot of things in his
life change so I kind of liked his story
going into this this fight like yeah it
became like a better man you know you're
kind of rooting for him you like you
know what man like this dude and he's
always worked hard he's never been about
him not working hard it's about his
in-ring IQ like making changes on the
fly he's never been good at that and he
can't change his game plan mid-fight do
it and that's what I was talking about
like he goes at one speed right if he
can vary the speed on his jab like half
jab soft death step in move back jab tap
tap then go full speed but this boy
always is full there and once they start
timing him once you taught if he fight
in the timing boxing he's done because
when the timing box that catches him
he's finished like I would never had the
money for daddy go see if I knew Danny
was gonna knock his ass out
I know how and I knew Danny was gonna
knock him out because Danny's a timing
fighter but what did Danny and agent one
sorry dad that blind right hand was so
beautiful
yesterday the green love oh I watch that
that was good fraud now nobody named I
just know I like match suit he
definitely on it um he started off early
like I said he needed to do and he got
him out there a little bit earlier than
I expected I gave Beatles to the man
from town front out of respect for his
boxer technique and his footwork and but
I just didn't expect Danny to hit him so
clean and so strong all thread and
punches he hit him when he hit him with
the down to block he went to the other
side yeah I know I must be like I I
think I think Danny's great but I think
he's he's an old young fighter too like
I just saw that he just felt slow to me
but again I think you know he's still
power wise and technique wise like he's
up there Granado so obviously like he
was using I'll sign him but I just still
see things in Danny like I don't think
he really yeah he is the new age
Trinidad if you move your feet on him
that footwork befuddles Danny
yeah if when he for Keith Thurman and he
Shawn Porter they could not bang with
Danny
so man the whole thing was let's give
him movement movement alright so we can
get him out I give him angles
other spots split decisions oh and he
has a strong chin so he's gonna catch
you and he did he broke Keith Thurman's
rib and broke his elbow um he uh this
guy had to get shoulder surgery Shawn
Porter no no no he had a rotator cuff
damage after that fight messing with him
um
Danny Danny can fight he has to be
matched properly like with certain
fighters if you give them like if you
put them in will bud yeah what blood is
gonna do is dance and box around a boxer
nobody really want us to tussle with him
cuz no wrong they don't have to know God
okay I got oh right now I just finished
the real boxing depression rate that I
get this is what y'all don't see in the
background yo is this up this is gonna
happen you know so I'm like alright I'm
getting a show up is I got a presented
to you guys differently so what I was
told is I have to get out god oh and I
have to capture footage of it without me
playing it like I'm putting it from a
remote place and I got to put it up with
us saying this is footage captured you
know I got to do a disclaimer on a joint
this is emulation and his rules against
this apparently a you know you've been
rocking on that nothing that knows no no
I was playing um Division two with uh
Lord Chris and hot monkey love him and
Lord we got we got we got a Duke all
Lord Lord
Bart yeah I made him a lord
this dude is like the Guru is like my
Yoda he's in my backpack
you know you should get this and break
this down your [ __ ] or whatever the hell
and I'm like okay Lord Bart yeah and he
has taught me more about the division
and I shall be returning this week I
already know for yeah that's pretty much
it but King I see yes and so of course
we have the Lord of the cooperative
experience and gaming into himself the
shinobi
I feel good to say that Lord Cognito
spreading everyone is in the Roman ILP
now tell me what you wanted him and what
you need to hear so first off no gaming
talk
so the first that past three weeks y'all
it's been extremely rough like on many
levels
I'm officially obviously late my brother
to rest he's still with me Lord whisky
my aunt passed as well and then I had a
medical procedures which I'm still
recovering from but I want to thank my
brothers at the round table for always
checking in keeping my spirits high
helping me push through each y'all did
tremendous just holding the fort down
solve I appreciate you brother you
already know you know I'm saying a dick
thank you so much for the retweets and
the engagement and doing getting things
in and King with the energy you know I'm
saying y'all was helping me laugh and
I'm saying I needed that so I want to
thank y'all for holding it down and I do
want to give us a couple special
shoutouts you know I'm saying Lords in
the realm so it was just kind of checked
on me you know I'm saying so sinister I
see you in there mr. ha Neal II bonta's
boy J Fonzarelli dizzy in the chat you
know centric when yo L bugs just Gordon
John Lennon man my boy Reaper le Quy
Basu of course he's actually have some
pneumonia wrap up you're not doing well
right now make sure make sure y'all says
some love the breath I'm saying Eric
Jackson my man you know saying undead
boom of course
Calvin take a comment and of course my
boy meds from the fight culture podcast
please check him out him and Fonz got a
nice little podcast going on so anyone
else I forgot
you'll thank y'all much appreciate you
guys have no idea no check-in job we got
to check each other only child in the
community like that stuff it really
helped my spirit you know I'm saying so
through the tough times so it's good to
be talking back games very therapeutic
so solve man let's get into these topics
man I thought I was harassing you not
like see me and I'll be like yo that's
what's up you know they're like yeah
how you feeling you know I'm saying like
that little stuff y'all understand like
I'm a troll it matters it matters man
and that's what we gotta do in this
community for real
I love y'all so if I see say like oh yes
oh honey I'm trying to rest up I'm like
yeah you need to heal then I go into man
stuff like so bogus Creek active you
[Laughter]
shake going on no Pozos but there will
be one at the end of the show but we go
get into these topics show unless
anybody anything else to say but um yeah
we got actually before we set it off
with Sava I know he's chomping at the
bit about his topic you know we'll get
to when we get to breaking news kind of
situations you know I'm saying so I
wanted to start us off with the hot off
the presses kind of thing and the first
one actually involves our Hale infinite
and on what we did realize is that you
had 343 initially he has said they were
not going to do a battle royale mode so
it come in tension that Lord
Brad Sam's good friend of the show good
to see him oh wow hold on one sec we got
to pay the bills
daddy always no lie
I want to rub the hawk statue for good
look like the cat daddy hit me before
the show on some real ill salute that
brother gets my do yo that's real wood
Rovers wood this is my car
first thing going awesome preparing what
is digging investigating reporting you
know I'm saying is apparently they're
going to do some three four three is
looking into some type of their own spin
on Battle Royale as experience uh-huh
let me you know I'm saying so that's the
first thing and then the second day
another end it respected in the insider
about Cobra I believe you got it from um
one of the messages boy we said era and
it's all ninja theory and basically you
know we all we are we are being told
that they're gonna present something at
e3 this year and um you know the vibes
right now is that it's a story based
four player co-op sci-fi game with an
emphasis on melee combat each character
can pick different abilities from the
secondary text is guns there's traps
there's a lasso which acts like one in
bullet storm 18 levels supposed to be
Unreal Engine 4 just like hell blade but
a faster paced game and I don't mean
King we talked about this it's long term
project yet in development for six years
so these are the rumors of what's going
on I want to start off with a dick first
on battle royale I've gone and I've been
hearing a lot of conversations which are
in these streets so Lord addict what do
we feel about the halo infinite battle
royal rumors um
I like it actually wow he's coming
around I just I've always said that they
can make a good battle royale game I
mean they everyone be ODST they do the
the pod drops mm-hmm that's how you fall
they got plenty of guns to switch to
they can do like a map of reach for a
mat for the madly no kidding
okay so it now dis now we know how
strongly you feel about chief and the
story of of halo battle rod doesn't
really have a story you can stand on its
own everything so your whole thing is
this is a separate mole this shouldn't
affect anything you good yeah oh wow
okay all right I'll be back trying to be
double up on now what about the ninja
Terry thing now what are we about the
whole like four player co-op um thing
like how do you feel about these rumors
if that's true
uh I've known about it for a couple
weeks insider oh double-barrel game I
was told by someone else that they were
doing it they actually exact words is
Microsoft's good you get blamed for them
not making a single-player experience ed
yeah I went talking about that too you
feel about your somewhat based on the
framework of the game structure I'm not
sure if it's if it's something they can
work on for six years it kind of worries
me a little bit because usually games
that's been around that long and
development that long which I don't
think this games been open development
for six years but so like the the
concrete in the foundation a game could
be built on six years ago is not
necessarily something that people would
want to play now fair enough
so they could be building something
before the what was popular before hero
shooting over watching them right if you
make a hero shooter these days it would
be played but it's not going to be
popular we're talking about look for
then that's not really hot trash yeah I
think it way is in a way how it's
described it sounds kind of like for
honor like what would you sort of what
Ubisoft did before on obviously is
different but I was like a better
version of uh what's that game called
the one that was just strange for gay
yep no Cody Asche disrespect I like is
fun it was fight like a little fun
mindless fun kind of thing
when injured theories that brace
themselves is the combat I'm it is gonna
be melee combat that is this specialty
that's what they've that's what shines
most in all of their games and so I
don't I want to see what it is that that
hand-to-hand stuff with them is always
very good so I want to see that but I
don't know about the you know the the
multiplayer aspects of it I'd rather
just have a story based thing from them
mm-hmm funny you say that
let me ask you this also what about the
whole halo infinity like where you at
with the hub I told you I was coming I
mean it was never gonna be oh it's only
battle royale I was never gonna happen
it was never gonna be a halo battle
royal on its own off to the side but I
knew I mean especially after hearing how
much money they're spending on the game
you're gonna have a battle royale and I
think like I got attic said like they
can do something really cool with it you
know we've seen that with with apex you
can make changes to battle royale and
make it fresh and not be you know
exactly the same formula over and over
again I think we're halo halos in the
unique position that they have like like
you know like that except like the way
they dropped they can do a lot of
different things differently and that's
what I want to see something different
and it make it still feel like halo like
what I would like for them to do is
everyone's a no DSD and you know you
could do certain things and like
Spartans will show up on the Mac or you
know and you you get extra points for
killing like you know the crisis and
buggy and stuff like right the have the
same crates drop down what's yahrens
protective yeah I think I agree I would
not want to actually be a Spartan in its
battle royale Moger I think the I think
has always been interesting the fact
that like like with ODST you're a human
you don't have those powers you don't
have those abilities you have
limitations that make the gameplay feel
different so oh yeah I would look that
well no - I'll cut a daily halo he says
I play Halo every day I think it's fun
salute you you got the perfect name the
daily Halo yes oh but what about learn
about let me bring it back before I give
it the kick I don't kick him out the
door
um what about like warzone like do you
think warzone gets a limit for the Lutra
wasn't like is it
that was supposed to be like the premium
Oh remember because he says oh okay um
first and before the halo thing um I
believe the Ninja Theory game is gonna
be overcooked
just like that exactly I believe the
foundation and basis the six years ago
it doesn't hold into this weight and I
really don't when I heard was six years
and it was a passion project I'm like
there we go so anything if it were that
is just be sitting six years for reason
think about it right that another game
leapfrog and got out and got critically
acclaimed so whoever the investors were
at that time they probably kept showing
them like yeah but we got this over here
they're like what's this and it's like
oh this one is okay so this is like the
lineage of heavenly blade like it here
so but you know we also do have a
cosplayer they had a wack music track
and everybody's like now you know what
that listen to my verse on this one
well they what I like what they did
about warzone is it always evolved like
they always put new there was actually a
boss that they put in from Halo Wars two
that came from that it was the big giant
um the big giant grunt they made that
into a leader in Halo Wars so it might
do that in this battle royal and what
I'm thinking is everybody's little OTS
T's right everybody calm down and then
you know one shot one kill but also that
there's bosses in the board that if you
kill them that you can get a powerful
weapon from them instead of loot crate's
dropping there's actual bosses that you
can fight and that you can kill you can
get a super weapon from them that can
help you you know get that chicken there
at the end so how are you are you
looking at only a team-based battle
royal are you looking at a mode that
that's anywhere from I believe this is
gonna be a real and for itself
no I think you'll be tanned
okay theory slanted at King on cuz we
can't let this fly I mean they could be
good like like it's a four-player car
thing like they don'ts like it when you
start read then that when you start
saying like 18 stages like that makes me
think it's not story you sir surrounding
because usually word stuff like that if
it's made with some perspective you
would say you would say four player
co-op will foot like a great story or
some stuff like you don't say it's
stages because that makes me feels like
this the stages that you put in
afterwards so what about what about
Kings point that is BC he said like it's
not hot obviously I mean these guys are
not dumb right they're not gonna sit you
look at a six year old I don't think
they're gonna sit there and look at a
six year old project and look at him be
like yeah this is still gonna rock in
2020 like I don't they would have to
reassess stuff if that's what the case
yo listen so they didn't have the money
to throw this game out this so Microsoft
came with the bag and they looked over
yo guess what is a goal or not what I do
worry about is that if they succumbed a
little bit to the pressure of having
something ready to go either long to the
new console they you know it's still
reporting a hell-blade or whatever the
case may be didn't have anything to go
on whatever else they're truly brand new
IPs and they're like yeah let's revisit
this thing that we put on the Shelf to
do held late we saw we do know remember
when the studios came out and they were
talking to failed before Phil was
throwing a bag Robin but Phil's doing
bad and that the statement was that they
were going around and that there was one
game that we haven't seen that was the
really impressive day right and I wasn't
helpless so what if this was the game
though what is it that impressive that
guys like I if the combat is there
that's where they shine the combats
there I think it'll be fine you know I
we don't know anything about it right we
don't worry
oh here's the thing like the way they're
making it seem what's one of the
number-one features that people loved
about heavily audio and the way they're
talking about it that's not gonna be in
this no but an audio chip to make it
work
I want Microsoft is like that space and
have remake it because I think they're
the only studio around they can make a
dead space because of that like that
psychosis things like that's what made
them what they are right now like people
remember that you know because it's
arrow if you guys play Hellboy makes a
great point is that again I said this
briefly before they've never made a game
like this a multiplayer game like this
thing their thing has always been story
based single player combat intense like
this would be brand-new balloon ever
made fortnight so they made fortnight
know how it goes when you get that extra
money and you know normally you go and
you get your ham and eggs and cheese in
the morning and you go to work now you
got the extra money and you look you say
man I have a little extra I could try
that thing that I've always wanted to
try okay then you purchase that thing
that you've always wanted to try and it
ends horribly for all even man I wasted
my extra money on this crap that I've
been looking at for the past two years
and I finally had the extra money to buy
this and this was the worst decision of
my long game is gonna come out
everybody's gonna be like see I told you
Microsoft is messing it up again before
like hell play - I prefer having like
every toy to never get heavily score I
prefer that I've been looking for that
game for the past 20 years
I prefer anything but what this is
just doesn't feel like what they make
alright I wanna see let me jumping yeah
yeah out of control
listen I feel where you're going because
we got hell-blade and I will say this is
this the only part I will agree with
y'all's days like when I heard about it
first time co-op so you don't buy
something like what I'm hearing
but at the end of the day when I did
hear I'm like damn like it almost feels
I just hope it's not a scalebound
situation right and it sense that like
that's the first case well in a sense
they're like we always know Microsoft to
always doodled Oh play a cooperative
joint right and for once I was hoping we
get like another single-player cinematic
hell Blade II kind of flow just so that
because let's be real like Sony got that
Lane right I just would love to see
Microsoft kind of get something out of
those studios in that vein when one I
think that's doing that right now is out
of worlds right ways off with always and
it's still kind of a this sort of an
open-world still right not really but it
is story based yeah and of course
whatever's coming out of uh what if the
initiative I guess who is gonna be you
know some big story based thing or
whatever you hope again I just want them
to like I said we know what they do well
co-op multiplayer all that I'm with that
but it's just like I just wish was that
this case but I wanted to give this a
chance no I do sound cool but I'm just
worried you all over to see what it is
is a game pass oh this is the game that
they were working on before Microsoft
even approached them like this this
isn't Microsoft influenced so with this
st. the game remember they said there
was a game that nobody's seen that
microsomes like yo that's it that's what
I got cooking I think that's I think
that's another studio oh let me tell you
something didn't gain it they was
shopping then everybody kept asking and
what is their hell bling right everybody
was like yeah that's nice yeah what does
that help like the Jackson 5 the father
Jackson was acting yeah so Jackson and
his kids around I was like yo Tito
there goes your hard drive my Kudo
nobody wanted to listen to Tino
christina but they was like that Michael
go that my kid is legit and we don't
never got a chance and then we turn a
photo album
it was hot garbage gonna be hot Michael
in the distributor and they got the bag
and he gonna put me nobody wants to hear
Jermaine Jackson nobody wants to hear
Tito's revision assistant nobody wanna
hear melodies they want that Mike if
they were smart they do hell-blade to or
heavily SOI to just stay in their Lane
gets smart dude and now they want to
branch off and give me that muumuu and
I'm telling you do new is old own it's
like old people actually love these if
you did damn fairy stuff like this makes
me to get to that new Michael so tell
the truth like you just set your own
self up track what's wrong with Jenna
what's up with Jenny you really wasn't
buying Oh Janet albums for the Superbowl
better whaddaya know how mumble rappers
video means but I will say this I like
if this is true I like how they
implemented
as a mold on the side as a part of a
whole game that I'm my issue with the
mumble rap battle royal game is that
that's the game and that's it and they
think and I'm just willing to say yeah a
chicken dinner and that's I'm supposed
to be happy with that gameplay loop
that's my issue with Battle Royale like
everybody's doing a copycat but this I
can see it work I'm with addict I can
see it working on some you know long as
they not Spartans out out the air and
some I do mumble rap needs killing off
the real nice analogy mob exact listen
I'm cool with them as a side mo my thing
is just don't make halo been rolling
that's like yeah it's the new game it's
still mumble Rev I like them versus with
Amy you're judging me kick is the Joe
Jackson
with us all I got on this so we'll see
what the hell blade thing is man you
know Lucy III don't know what to make of
it until I see it in action
but that's all I got Lord sovereign
hello ready for Sunday let's get the
formalities out of here I see King has a
nice wide angle camera
[Applause]
all right we both agree that I mean you
agree that there would be no
compatibility but that they would Saudi
with charge and we agreed that it was
one knee per we agreed so only was back
compare or no he lost that need 12
terrify making it I think we won no no
nobody giving no because when that you
eat ship and you put the PlayStation 4
disc in and si is gonna have a side
compartment with them you will swipe
your card on the side for 95
that joint don't do no backup at for
free Dean never give you anything in
this life of free free for games that
you had you don't actually own on
PlayStation but of course you be sure
you have it already I'm willing to
concede a bunch of both knees are mine
I'm willing to concede I'll spare him
and then just get him you know I'm crazy
later is this right we're not going on
for snake oil salesman be right all
[ __ ] changes is when they get
physical stuff in the house but damn
when they in when you get it they're
gonna say but what we were meant to say
after you purchase it then they give you
to stipulate then you read the fine
print
Megatron Megatron said you got to do it
over bro he said knees gone y'all saw
him in person shake your hand that dude
that you watch him released and then we
see it and we got it so hard this King
is crawling on the knees right now let's
just go into the spectrum we're going on
here so let's just get into like what
was always said right so let's get into
the specs real quick right so this the
CPUs gonna be a and E chip based on on
risin it's gonna be an octa-core
processor seven
Zen - so uh the seven nanometers is
what's exciting to me right anytime you
give me more power efficiency and the
fact that that's barely a thing on the
in the PC market I'm excited about so
and I expect I fully expect the next
Xbox to incorporate that eggs well um
now the GPU stuff this is where I guess
interesting I know this is where King
gave it the Quine that mm-hmm
I'm just letting you finish right now
because I'm here to crush these little
PlayStation guys and you will tell me
what happens after this the PS 5 DP um
is gonna be a custom Navi GPU apparently
they've indicated that it supports
ray-tracing
we'll see about that we'll see to what
level of supports rates racing right um
another thing that I gave a little bit
of a side I too was this 3d audio sort
of solution that screams of dobby at
most but just with a different name
about that um actually the most another
thing I gave a side I - was that the 8k
support she said it will have a king it
will be able to display a k-9 let me
give you something a little-known fact I
got it on TV that's in it a 720 I mean
I'm 1080p is the highest level of 1080p
but on the box
it's a can display 4k content right so
like Oh cuz I brought it and hopefully
oh my TV is 4k no stupid your TV is not
4k it can display for take the 4k
content so I put it on the thumbnail 4k
picture cuz you can only do a 4k picture
and I put inside and I said boom like
number one sovereign TV it coulda said
it could do 1080p right where my purse
one of the per Sony Vegas that I had
everybody else TV do you know the
servants whatever for for TP whatever we
was doing we doing it fine right and
then we get two sovereigns high scan and
Jewett was in a box
inside the screen we've like what the
hell is going on here that's level 20 P
that's exactly what what my TV inside
the basement does right is the top level
1080p just great 1080p when you get to
4k content it's a little box I know
y'all are hungry for something new right
and I have a problem with you Sony dudes
when it comes to talking about the next
level a lot of you dudes don't have a 4k
television that's right and let me
explain why because I went in on a
couple of you dudes online now a lot of
you guys do not have a 4k television we
yelling 8k if you have you looked at the
prices for a cake I put an affordable
cheap on 4k televisions in there for you
guys that didn't level up yet half you
guys don't even got a pro indications of
the cheap and poor sales that a
PlayStation Pro all right so y'all fine
with the base because y'all felt there
was really no difference from the base
and to the unpro you know why was no
difference for you because you didn't
have a 4k television that's why I was no
difference for you so y'all talking a k
like you're really gonna be an 8k you
are not doing a cake it was just a nice
talking point because you're getting
your teeth kicked in right now from X so
you're like yo 8k is gonna be the thing
it's still not more powerful than
anaconda still not something you're
sitting there touting something that
they still can't do remember PlayStation
Pro is supposedly able to display in 4k
content No it displays checkerboard so
you're gonna get checkerboard 8k and you
can't do a que anyway so why are you
worrying about
8k so let's take that off the table
let's go what the marks are really
talking about okay sir the audio for her
so the audio thing the audio thing to me
he said some weird thing about now you
can utilize ray-tracing for the audio as
well like it was it was just a very
weird it was
it was that death snake or the king
talks about it was like you're you're
speaking in terms to sort of wow people
we're not necessarily getting giving
anybody any real information as to how
this works and it just rang up dolby
atmos to me they never supported that
most outright so to me is like okay this
is their version of dolby atmos so we'll
see what it is they're indicating some
sort of hardware you know down to the
metal solution we will see the thing
that was most interesting to me and
exciting for me was the storage talk at
first I thought it was crazy but
apparently they and this and it sounds
super expensive as well they're looking
to use the new PCI Express 4.0 bus which
isn't even necessarily available on pcs
yet which what it will do is see if you
on a ps4 Pro if you just pop in a
regular SSD now you're not gonna see
much of a difference because it's not
optimized for it same same goes for and
any old SSD isn't they aren't
necessarily all created equal right when
you look at the the faster SSDs now see
the the v2 or whatever the MB tattoos
these things are sort of produced
specifically to push information quickly
in in a specific way along a certain
track and according to you know what
what's being said in this article it's a
P it's PCI Express 4.0 specifically
geared for developers did to make the
game to utilize its power and speed in
terms of loading and everything like
that now that's fantastic now that's in
fact if it's true it's fantastic but
it's potentially super expensive it
potentially makes it so that you can use
external storage just for storage and
anything that you actually want to play
utilizing this tech you'd have to
definitely download directly to to the
internal hard drive of the PS 5 or
whatever it's gonna be haul um that said
I don't like a 1 terabyte internal drive
that utilizes its tech sound expensive
sounds expensive so we'll see how true
it is
it's impressive if it is true
so overall yes I think a couple of
things about this announcement
announcement were brilliant they they
didn't be wired they did it rewired
right because this is what you have to
remember right this is not for us this
this announcement isn't for us is to get
the other dude do I read Wired magazine
no no that was a bit right right but if
you think about it and they really
wanted us to if it matter to them that
we the mass right they would have gone
around you with this right with nothing
right they never take oh but I thought
it was brilliant they're doing that
because they want to appeal to the
masses they don't care about that 10
million that they sell to the hardcore
they care about this 80 million they
sell afterwards today to the right the
average guys they're the cult followers
exactly so that that was to me big and
the fact that they announced it the same
day is that inside Xbox and he knew that
the SHA day was gonna be talked about it
is apples to oranges right you're
talking about a next-gen machine to
whatever but I think you know when it
came down to Microsoft and what they
talked about and how they presented the
SHA day it just it just as bad look it's
bad optics regardless of how how much
they don't actually compare have
anything to do with one brush so I don't
think you think they try to steal the
new cycle implants are absolutely I
think that was you know that was
definitely on purpose
all right before I gotta get em you know
he's the big power guy I know you know
like what do you feel like are you
impressed with what you heard so far is
there anything that excites you in
reference to the PlayStation prospects I
don't care anything PlayStation 5 I have
an answer I don't care about you have a
dense metal gear they are you as long as
it plays the games that I wanted to play
I've never been on that X that thing
what about the backward compatibility
sir does that excite you Robbie had that
on Xbox oh it's about time PlayStation
catchy so specs why's that you you don't
care about your whole thing you always
been just give me the games that's where
you won't care about right sorry
games yeah I actually mean that when I
say that there's a lot of people that
die all right no doubt fair no fair that
Fanny Lord King why do you think there
front of me getting it back to you again
Oh break down all of this stuff and I'm
here to put blood in all you smoke oh
let's go old language let's start off
with the SSD drive right anybody
listening no shout out to Megatron and
anybody else this in and oh no about the
white papers they're going on in
Microsoft inand any hardware being large
from surface Pro's up starting I think
it was a yeah 2019 and on was supposed
to have solid-state hard drives in it
right okay so any new hardware new
that's existing Hardware on the
Microsoft and new hardware will have
SSDs
all right knowing that that you know
solid-state hard drives is going to be a
thing in the future because they are
actually the wave okay you can hook up a
solid state hard drive to your existing
systems right now and load in quicker on
a regular base system alright my friend
has a regular base Xbox and he loads
into destiny faster than me with my ex
and I'm always pissed off and I'm always
saying how are you doing this is because
he has a solid-state hard alright now
let's get that out the way when they
announce rate race and they give any
little buzz words to click on to because
but right now ray tracing is the rage
right you can do rate racing right now
with your existing systems and it's
looking software so again that right
there meant absolutely nothing but the
zoom in zoom all right now let's go on
into the audio dolby atmos is inside
your xbox is right now sony never
supported dolby atmos so they want to
bring a level of immersion with sound
right in they wants you to fall in line
with it so they're telling you from a
chip level that it's in there the reason
why they're telling you about the sound
because graphically they can't compare
to whatever microsoft alright but they
like
you're gonna hear things fun it is what
it is right so Microsoft right now you
see these headsets brain Dolby Atmos
okay I got it right upstairs right now
I'm hearing things front back side to
side when I put my joint on when I play
a plug gee I hate a dude I know he had
fax do y'all hear that in PlayStation I
really don't think so
all right because they don't support
that type of audio but now you get that
with your PlayStation practice that is
the most most impressive thing that I
heard coming out of that was sound if
you look at it there VR did they're
gearing you they're setting you up an 18
you up for VR all right with the headset
now why sound so important why is he
telling you in audio mmm it's going to
be the new driving force right when I
put on my headset why must I wear
worried are you trying to say he's catch
boxer he's controlling the bereted from
they trying to get away from the
teraflops and trying to focus on the
hoods of what they're doing with VR and
is that what you're implying and what
they saying right now he used a lot of
buzzwords to get you guys all riled up
and nice and will added up and read your
breakthrough he told us you guys didn't
know what an SSD was and it guys they
did know what an SSD was new
common-sense wise is gonna be in every
system going forward right maybe not the
Nintendo but um all premia systems right
okay then he said ray-tracing yeah oh I
heard about that
with that new graphics card so if they
doing what a new 600 $700 graphics card
is booing you know this system that's
$400 it's definitely gonna be bigger
think what you think with your brain now
you know it's not just for hacks I want
y'all to use this right so okay now the
audio is what they're pushing forward
for the VR this next system is gonna be
about VR the 18s you just say he did say
meant nothing about teraflops let's move
away from teraflops let's step away
let's move back
for the teraflops and allow Microsoft to
own a teraflop market well we're trying
to get to is that 8k display the Lord
gave a dinette in the building 20
dollars super chat make sure you guys
are hitting that like button subscribe
hit that Bell check that website support
the best cast on Sunday that shows all
love back to the community
let's make IOP the official podcast for
next year my brother my boy dizzy will
fail or Adam in the realm can continue
why to configure tell us why my attorney
is fooling us you clear clearly blue you
know this is his project
alright so he's gonna highlight the pros
of his project he's gonna give you
buzzwords for his project he's not gonna
give you the pitfalls on the downfalls
right I didn't hear anything that made I
was just like why was this announcement
made oh ok cuz you had nothing in the
new cycle and Microsoft was about to do
fanfest to get people in are engaged and
they was about to talk about the new
digital sister Andrew being on you he
said only King could come up with this
nice if you feel is nonsense right and
this is what I say if you feel is
nonsense point holes into anything that
I told you that was wrong
just yes I want you to to objectively
look at what I just told you the most
important thing that he told you in
there was audio mmm that's what he said
he said the most important thing that
you're gonna take from this is audio you
gonna sit there and say I can unload
into spider-man faster then I can load
into it with the next system mmm
foolish mortal and I want you to go back
to your PlayStation 1 mmm low times were
longer right every new system at all
times or minimize alright so basically
look for what is your base what you
saying is kind of similar what's
obviously in a sense that is common
sense a lot of these things you're not
really surprised by line right and it
did you feel that
Kesava saying applying that even though
stuff was said structurally from the APU
to GPU we really don't have those true
details yet to really figure out what
they
stinging it's kind of what digital
foundry saying right yes just how
powerful it is my thing is they will
king says is like okay gotta play a
little bit of a devil's advocate right
and I'll go back to the storage thing
the stores thing it's not just it's not
as simple as you say King about dropping
the SSD in there like it's not yet it is
proprietary and they're claiming that
right have unique speeds that are faster
than any current as that current PC bro
no I get that guy sovereign let you
finish no no that's exactly what I was
gonna say it's like David they've made
claims about speeds and and it's not
just about loading into the world it's
about how you stream the world and how
you get information off of that SSD mid
gameplay there's gonna be a game changer
for gameplay so again I don't know how
true this is right he was they
apparently they mentioned that during
the during the actual interview that
they were showing this you know he like
whatever the dev kit is was being
covered up you know everything is very
super secretive so we don't know what's
under the bottom what's under the hood
there but if that is true right and and
and all signs point to that it can be
true it can be it may be expensive but
it can be true it's something that I
think is a game changer that Microsoft
has to has to follow suit with this is
good this is good tech stuff a lot of
other stuff I'm working to an extent I
understand where he's going look at the
end of the day where I'm with King is
that I'm not surprised right because not
everybody has a gamer as far as been
following next-gen I felt I would get
some shoutouts just dizzy gave some shot
I wanna shout out lower mods tremendous
articles on Lords of gaming dotnet he's
been ahead of this man he's been saying
you know I'm saying
AMD rising line you know I'm saying a
cause to saying you know descent to
seven nanometer you know I'm saying like
he's been on it so that I will say this
though what excites me is the fact that
it is in because yo King rest in peace
time Jaguars yo yeah I've been the bane
of my console era quit I'm saying like
because at the end of the days I used to
bottle next one the frame rates man like
I'm just I
that's what kills my destiny on PC
versus yeah I just can't but and what
the SSD
shelter cops coming through right now
the SS deed has supposedly room it
faster than the current SSD I'm
definitely excited to see how that's
gonna be that's gonna be a game changer
like when you load up and ant them you
load up all that stuff on PC or SSD it
is next level y'all like it really is
fast now this is where I'm back on
kingside with the rage rate racing we
could talk about that let's talk about
it cuz at the end of the day like the
ray-tracing you know I'm saying that
commitment I got to see what extent
because saw we know a choice is a
resource hog like that that thinks so I
got a see to what extent and then if
they talking about you know to me the
bottom be relative ah by get is on a
software level
I don't yeah I don't think yeah I don't
know that there is a hardware
implementation something something to
aid in the rate racing hardware that's
wise that they otherwise they would have
talked about it I think at least mention
that they had a hardware solution so am
i thinking it is a software base and
when you're doing it software based on
hardware there isn't necessarily built
specifically for that it's super it's
super intensive right it's super CPU
intensive it so the question at this
point is can it be done theoretically
yes you probably running the game at
720p um let me speak specifically to
this like so you know recently Nvidia
opened up the that 10 the 10 10 series
cards to uh to ray-tracing right so I
immediately went in boom my 10 60 on my
laptop and I downloaded all those demos
to see how they run slideshow right so
it goes back to the old adage like just
because you can do something doesn't
necessarily mean you should so I think
it'll be it'll be in the same vein of
what we saw with the pro and what we saw
with the ex that they're gonna give you
options I'd be like ok you want to run
the game at 1080 60 you want to run it
at 4k 30 you want to run it at 8k 24
whatever the hell um and it'll beat
they'll probably be a rate racing option
they'll be like
gonna be there the options are gonna be
the same way they're gonna give you in
that ray-tracing option is going to be
low resolution low resolution fairly low
framerate oh we keep talking like these
things as facts this is your hope that
they gonna do something in this fashion
first of all I'm telling you right now
they're not doing okay all right I'm
coming it's not the we we know there's
these dudes is out here really run
around with the a keg and you know how
many people for came in he was 4k to
beast okay let's see let me tell you let
me tell you how that marks marks
learning is a snake-oil system why me
tell you why when the most demanding
game this generation what's the most
demanding game this generation sovereign
this generation yeah this generation the
most demanding game red deck okay now
when mote when red dead ones and 4k
native on that X right does it run in 4k
native on that Pro okay so y'all got
dynamic 4k and I'll tell you we're gonna
do some dynamic stuff now maybe you
might do some dynamic 8k but let's be
upfront with these dudes from the
beginning let's let's let's you see what
they do is they hype up these little
wars in between each other race I saw
all these guys running around with a K
what now bro that's why said it was
brilliant that they were wired because
the a K that appeals to the dude is
reading wired right oh my god they're
doing this like that gets them
interested in in in the machine in a way
that somebody who's in the know that's
going to digital found you for this
stuff that it's more to know about the
the tech stuff behind it like it could
you control the narrative you get your
basic side we know they're not going to
be nice and narrow and now the thing is
that now all of that is associated with
them they came out first now narrative
is my caused by it so I'm trying to say
you gotta respect the dude that was
yelling out a K has a 720 television I
paid 10 grand for my 4k television
upstairs
no I in another TV you're not happening
and I sort of prices on a Katy B to the
bushes with them joints all right 18,000
yeah you know what 18,000 happier cause
only like 400 hours so you you about
television you really go my lord MJ he
was telling me he's like man he's like
it's like that's almost what I pay in
tuition next year's shout out this thing
in the chat he said there's one issue
though he said they gave Microsoft
almost two mumps to adjust that's what I
saying like Paul even though I do agree
with solve that again they gave a nice
framework stuff right stuff that we kind
of know the hawk or will kind of know
but buzz words for the cash that don't
know and excited that this thing is
going to be a beast but don't you think
since you know you're filled ominous
you're the guy that's your guy right
right but don't you think that is gives
by them kind of doing this move and a
sense gives micro time to prepare well
listen Lori Barbara oh shut up slaughter
bar Oh Lord of old gaming as cute as you
will do backs right yeah that's a lotta
bar for saying that Microsoft stuff that
they got working all right now is my
fake it's visually we do party exit them
do that good the cast brass answered all
bye
I want you to understand something right
y'all yelling now all this stuff is
happening and all this stuff is moving
III things would be addressed
all right you would be addressed at e3
you will be addressed at and we we
talked about this Millions I just wish
like if that was really the case and
they had something that really blew this
out the frame I would have just liked to
have seen like like like Phil on Twitter
like a chuckle ha ha ha yeah but you do
that you got excite to face like if you
confident that you got one in the
chamber eyes you know I heard us doing
you know say like it's got the worst
Adia came out phil was like over poppin
off let's I gotta give King that joint
he was like wow that's cool you know he
spoke to Larry inside so as we're gonna
get into that with addicts topic you
know I'm saying but you know he was
kinda over okay ha ha yeah we got a lot
to show we excite excited so much [ __ ]
like he been in his petty bag lately I
have to give very petty let me finish up
my last point I'll give it back it's
just that yes so I mean a key thing to
me to me is just upscaled let's just
call it what it is it's proof kind of a
thing you need I don't feel that they're
gonna be doing stuff like that off the
ridge and refresh like I say like I'm
very excited about that stuff I mean but
to your points off no teraflop mention
statistic you know I'm saying anyway you
know what's funny babies okay yeah they
really was where I'm looking for they
kind of finesse people they special
about announcing specs lame I get what
y'all going digital foundry literally
said what you said shot the but she left
better talking on spec shout to my boy
John Lennon man talking them specs it
was
real good you know again we'll see
what's gonna happen but I just like I
think I'm impressed that the groundwork
was laid it does have a makings of a
beast oh we ain't gonna be totally
disrespectful it does have it I didn't
think they were gonna go as hard with
both the GPU API I respect that but I
agree with King in the sense that I
think Xbox is sitting back they're gonna
Trump some specs but here's the question
I got the ally we know when the X came
out right and we know the gap the vibe
I'm getting you that maybe the gap ain't
gonna be as big as we think not saying
that Microsoft ain't gonna Trump them
but my question is - y'all like don't
you I think they still kind of in Pocket
in a good space if the gap it's take
like x2 Pro is like this let's say the
gap is like this but they still got them
they gotta got the IPS the the way I
think Microsoft could address this
narrative now is with that to skew you
know release thing that we're expecting
with Lockhart and anaconda and I've said
it before if now that they see that this
is what the base ps5 is I doubt very
much there's going to be another skew of
a ps5 this is what it is this is the
framework for it so like I said before
if that Lockhart is even remotely close
to those specs and it's $100 cheaper who
don't say that what I'm saying is that
when they say it's close to it right or
reasonably close to it right it's $100 -
because even the hardest of the hard
core on the PlayStation side are
assuming this is a $500 console mmhmm
right so let's say this gives Microsoft
the opportunity to put the Anaconda even
what do you know whatever in the
stratosphere in terms of specs and the
Lockhart is even remotely comparable to
what that base ps5 is that's where I see
it some interesting numbers start to go
down but at the end of the day then and
they if they launch with like
blood-borne - another thing all of those
listen all of those games that are not
out yet are cross-gen games period
imagine if they it
launched it with all the because they
probably have PS five versions of the
Last of Us 2 goes to Kashima death
stranding and then they had the PS 5
exclusive games which is horizon zero
dawn two blood war two these games are
probably aiming to be launch titles and
not to mention they're probably gonna
have a what's our what's their their
whack-ass racing game yeah it's a
reasonable trick Gran Turismo like if
they launch with that like Microsoft
they cannot launch this with a ninja
Terry and I think I'm willing to bet
that that's what they're doing
yeah hedging that best like they all of
this stuff even if we do get last of us
to or whatever let's with the new
resistance game alright y'all thinking
they gonna put the day one day not
Nintendo coming out the gate banging you
in the face you're gonna get last of us
to pro so you double up that's all you
get back to double up mode that's all
you get ready so let's not gonna be just
the UH president it's gonna be the
double up mode like you played it here
or you could play to do double up mode
alright so that's why when you gonna put
the disc in it's gonna be four ninety
five you already know like Sony ain't
doing what Sony does this is Sony Holy
Smoke but this time you'll notice they
shut it down early it shut it down it
one they put their hands up you know
doesn't wanna champion throw their hands
up in the fighting over yet listen he
shut it down no III for you so don't
look forward to it
you're gonna little announcements here
and there because they don't be trying
to deflect and trying to slow down
people's momentum where people actually
got stuff to show all right the thing is
this we we y'all got information but you
got nothing like they give you a bag
there was like yours money in there you
open it up with newspaper you got [ __ ]
blam you got a New York shuffle and you
pick the bottom of the deck and you roll
you lie to yourself sitting here going
on with your life you're not you don't
got no 8k you just got a new version of
dolby atmos or your joint
they just pop it off yo you got a car
with four wheels they got the car with
the four words and the Bluetooth now
King we gotta give them the line of King
I don't think I don't think they've had
a stable to be able to do it they wanna
know I know I think they can do it this
time
because they'll have those guys shout
the frogs in the chat he said doesn't
matter if they have an Xbox system close
to the PS file specs are better most
people in the PlayStation ecosystem will
stay in that ecosystems resort of
PlayStation 5 thing unless Sony messes
up the launch pad but no III really do
think they're gonna do something to mess
it up I don't know what's gonna be a
little hot bigger house always mess up
they can do am i right do they connect
force PlayStation VR in the box yeah
yeah I think the way they can mess up is
price if they can I think they've got
the mess I think they better drop the
ball I mean that balls your turn into a
ball at the end of the day let's keep it
true and we are Xbox a lot of our
preferred console but at the end of the
day if this if the specs are compared
even if the LS cannon is even if the
Lockhart and the scroll is above it
right let's just say let's give it up to
X right like that ecosystem 100 million
whatever they are Michael you got to get
people to convert over to Microsoft Word
you still has this that the A+ banga
banga banga is the Xbox
Wanderlei station is not I don't they
becoming back they not necessarily that
I think it's it's gonna depend on the
launch titles I think they have a
competent halo and you know ninja
theories game isn't work like I think
it's gonna be I think they could pull it
off because I don't think Sony's coming
out with more than two games like of
their snow like that across but I think
those games have already gonna be played
so no one's gonna go over for those
games but I do see them like right now
we know that sure crow dies twice there
BT made that there no one knows what
they're 18s making I think it's
blood-borne - all right nothing is the
bread and butter
this is the litmus test fair enough with
the fraud or all right at it so they
come out with blood-borne - right and
you can play it on current gen or you
can get the PlayStation 5 version we
play it a little bit faster with a
higher res you played an actual 4k what
you can play it on your existing system
are you gonna invest the six to seven
hundred dollars into the PlayStation 5
are you gonna abide the $60 game to play
it on the existing system oh so you're
saying that people won't make the jump
just in general because of the fact that
that with the for compatibility there's
no need necessarily that's your that's
your argument that's why I said there's
gonna be across progressed a platform
game so you know a lot of people aren't
necessarily gonna go to that but you do
have your hardcore that's gonna bite
regardless right I don't think that's
gonna sell it but I do think if they
drop a blood-borne - no riding $0 - I
think that is gonna sell it exclusive -
to shut off the market I'm listen I'm
down with the PlayStation 4 I'm buying
the day one
hey guys oh I want you to understand I
said you talk all this crap to you guys
mm-hmm I'm already I'm able to preorder
it
I'm pre-ordering - all right though all
that and then you might catch me on eBay
with at least six
selling it to you fools they actually
want it so I'm gonna have it Ellie all
right and I'm gonna get to anaconda and
I'm gonna have it I'm gonna sell it I'm
just giving you what's going on next you
might not even have to make the jump for
the first two minutes but it to be
honest with you you know of Microsoft
buying these studios I don't think that
we're gonna see anything big off these
Studios for a couple years but um I do
think this is gonna be one of the very
few generations that power is not gonna
matter so much at the beginning of the
generation because the games you're
gonna be so fantastic why I'm going back
to what dizzy said to chase that Xbox
had a better have better have a better
launch lineup this gen though Sony's
probably holding on to one or more of
those titles is launched out of this
round
Microsoft has to be the link and that's
why titles to me like a halo infinite is
key now we do know that they're
investing a lot we keep hearing rumors
we keep hearing I've heard things behind
the scenes that I can't even comment on
you don't in reference to the level of
commitment that Microsoft has and we
know halos their babies right what yeah
what happens if the launch comes out you
get a halo you get the next four so
because by around that time the next
four is is going to be due and then you
have a fable once it that's a launch
title like that that those are good
launch play and I do think they can
compete because at the moment I think
last was twos across plant I think it's
gonna come out a couple months before
the next be smart real halo the if halo
is epic they want that's all they need
let's just a hold or halo halo
single-handedly may handedly do what it
do you know I'm saying if again they
listen the community it changes all what
the changes are and it's epic and it
just completely galvanizes the base and
the base is satisfied and you got
next-gen power behind this absolutely
well weed out real quick real quick what
if could there's also the rumor that's
only my forgo it was normal release
schedule and not release the console at
the end it all say that they roll of war
a switch you know what would be crazy
actually you you I just had an epiphany
you know you know when they launch the
PS 5 mm the day last was to comes out
exactly because it would make sense
because why won't even comment on the
Last of Us - because you can't comment
on it because it's the same day as PS 5
and they want to launch them both in the
same day they want to try a blazing
pocket stop it
he said power matters three years tell
us it doesn't and don't buy it and I
never will jealousy I tell you how to
exit and I feel you funny how it does
matter don't don't ever think it doesn't
you know listen teraflops will be talked
about ake a real resolutions will be
talked about there's no actual power is
gonna matter
but what Sony dudes now this is what
Sony dudes do they get a goal post and
it tells to you that we have the games I
want you to listen to these dudes when
it comes out and Sony's there's some
stupid like say 600 hours stupid like
600 dollars in the box cause you playing
for a sound chip or SSD drive they
didn't want to get you a little quicker
into the world room go in color switch
but they're gonna drop in March in Japan
then the ps4 come out first in the
States then it came out in Japan
yeah dad that doesn't hold water anymore
man that market info for actual console
stayin up what's up Xbox tax bucks look
I need oh yes I'm telling you right now
yes when they drop this they better not
give you the option of playing the top
tier game on the base system don't do
that and this is where you're gonna
split the crown make force them put the
gun to the head I think there's gonna be
five exclusives they always I think
there's gonna be the next Xbox exclusive
- you don't think they'd do it forever
I'm confused you
when the last of us to or whatever comes
out day it's only all place they survive
what sense would it make because you got
a hundred million systems that they
gonna make a lot of people mad what
sense would it make to upgrade your my
existent Pro if it's if it's the same
skew that's what I do say like if it's
to excuse if it's to excuse you piss
people off right but a power dudes
because they've been they had to take me
on power the last 200 checkerboard is
gonna be real focus so they claim what
would think is they go digital frowns
you go ahead at the comparison ps4 pros
low-pass happening you got a cartridge
care for it my attic is my needle I mean
if attic tells me you're buying a
Playstation from them my eyebrow goes oh
okay mmm then then I notice I know you
right now all they have to do to get me
to buy PS 5 is announce blood-borne 2 is
a launch title like but blah blah tools
a love style but it's backwardly
compatible on your protégée got right
now all right that's a good point let me
he's making a good point cuz addict is
you represents the masses right so in
this said you didn't need so it misses
that if the PS 5 comes out right and you
know you got your games you got your
Last of Us 2 but you also have the last
one was two on PlayStation 4 word all
the current horrid you that does do are
you incentivize to get the PlayStation
fire or you Oh Conway also he's gonna
tell you what's good when when addict
makes to move the massive is gonna make
them run inside an addict let me ask you
this then you know that was advocate
then what would make you
a playstation 5 you know and make the
jump boy born to launch title you exclu
what a blood boil dude this happens to
be on PlayStation 4 as well nothing
so until there's it so busy you say what
you have literally the only game I care
about on PlayStation so basically you're
agreeing with King in a sense that until
there's a PlayStation 5 exclusive only
game then you may never pay five hundred
dollars to play something I can play
right now so basically you're taking the
Xbox one esse provider that song will
take this approach that approach if I
can played on the content that the the
hardware I currently own why would I
ever upgrade anything else like mr.
goodkat agrees he said I'm with addict
on that one he said he's not gonna this
is interesting discussion King I don't
see the viability in doing for me I'm an
idiot all right look I brought multiple
versions of a game to see the resolution
I mean I'm not even trying to announce
your name man will butcher it he said
why I did cuz an Xbox said he's got no
credibility I didn't even buy the X for
the same reason so I'm gonna have to
throw that right back at you we was
implanted Xbox out probably what a time
do you offer that man addict went back
and forth on that whole X or it doesn't
he's the mean he's the pulse of the
community he needed an anomaly you know
you're right cat daddy agrees he said
this thing he said psy was also for
those would be us us with ps4 base
battles that skip the pro now that is
true though that's a good point those
thing is making there are people who
didn't buy into the mid generation
refresh they said to themselves yo
that's a half-measure
I'm a weak and do that so they could get
that market but what your your whole
thing is attic represents the majority
the base rules lowest common denominator
grew and that they're gonna stay there
if at launch if at launch the primary
reasons
get that system is our is games that are
already on the are coming out day and
date on for the ps4 yeah I could
I can see nobody or not nobody I can see
playing people saying now I'll wait
until they give a reason okay let's go
back to the being of this Jim wouldn't
when did you buy an xbox like when was
the what was the game that made you
bother the day one you know me you know
the only reason I bought an Xbox I
bought it like came out November I
bought it like the end of December what
he does a Dead Rising for three and you
knew that couldn't be done on and that
was the only game I cared about
I got you listen he said this is a good
discussion that we've been listening
double yellow and I thought I was under
the impression of favor was gonna come
out this [ __ ] so you know this is Val
this is it's gonna be curious to see how
this thing plays out a fantastic topic
Lord soft on Lord addict inside Xbox
remind me cuz I completely forgot what
my father's so I don't even remember
what I think was last Tuesday I don't
even know what day that was will say
last Tuesday they had an inside Xbox in
you know obviously that this is we're a
little bit into the inside Xbox days
we've probably had more than ten at this
point but from the it everyone here
watching inside Xbox last oh yes yeah
first of all I want to go to into a
couple of the statements that was made
on inside Xbox and I want to go like you
got a goodie statement and then I want
to go into inside Xbox as a whole a
first thing I wanted to go over is what
Phil said that uh you know at e3 it's a
big year for you there obviously that
could be PR talk happens every year but
he did say that there would be some
announcements from the new studios there
so one thing I want to ask is do you
guys think that he's breaking his I
don't want to announce anything that's
more than not more than two three years
away that's one thing and the next thing
I want to ask is do you think inside
Xbox a hole as a whole has improved
since
launch I won't jump in oh listen I gotta
be real with y'all like y'all know how I
feel about you know IRA it's really not
for me
I cringe moments discuss going on you
have many a sound clip in a video clip
has been made of me clowning inside Xbox
it's just not where I need it to be but
I will admit this last one I felt the
pacing was better it was less cringy not
they had no cringe but it was less
cringing and had announcements that I
cared about and the pacing was a little
better you know I'm Sam I know King me
King disagree on this part here
I do like arm ogre off no you go ahead
thing about everybody yeah I just feel
that they need a whole staff remake I
will say this now let's get to the I'm
just going to ask you a quick cuz your
question attic is just the first part is
like about to show itself like what I
feel about the show it's no the first
one was the statement Phil Spencer made
that you know he's got announcements
he's going some of the newer Studios are
gonna be there right and they're gonna
announce something like what do you
think of that statement do you think
that you know they might take be though
and even even low-key made a punch at
PlayStation like a low-key we're the
only you know major platform day we
actually gonna show up I sort of slap
you floating in his penny bag I beat it
listen I was cool I listen anytime
if it's up to me feel should be on that
show every month just when I mean it
stated address to the realm that's how I
so when I see that I'm like I'm tuned in
I got a watch
you know I'm saying and then for me the
announcements that they talking about
and then obviously fan fest this is a
big thing a lot in our community love
shot l blogs and a chat and everybody
we're gonna see every year that's all oh
you know communal thing for the thing so
that that's what I like to see you know
I'm saying to see that kind of stuff
like that important announcements you
know
Jaka saved me with Shazam playing xbox
with Charaka say I don't
that fluff that y'all doing the gloves
Oh about Swiss you'll give me got it
should be every month Phil should jump
on the Iron Throne and State of the
Union this is what's going on this is
what we doing yeah ah
that's what I got let me let me save
this one I need they need a staff
overhaul that's all right and maybe you
got you hit on something maybe Phil can
come in and soothe it up real quick yeah
we bring him in ahead and just walk off
the stage I feel that and I love his
petit I love his I loved what he said
mm-hmm it was eloquent in the statement
and he said that we feel that we have
the industry on our shoulders and they
have to stand up and show out for us
mm-hmm they representing us and I think
that's indicative of my frustration with
Playstation don't don't don't get it
wrong I purchased Sony I paint I use
them I utilize them I have a system I
have the head says to have all that
stuff and I've been a Sony support a few
years right what I don't like is that
they're taking my patronage for granted
and when you feel that you can do
anything and I still stand there that's
not how it works in any relationship has
to be a given to take and at this point
in time you're doing a whole lot of
taken and not a lot of giving and you're
not giving me no expectations on the
future you're not giving me any
expectations on anything that's like you
come home in a relationship you ask you
know what we're gonna do next year we're
gonna be and they give you some fake
fluff time to the same thing we doing
now bro you're not gonna stick around
for long
let's not work out for controllers and
riding our birdies I'm not liking it
yeah this this was the last one before
e3 and they're making a point to tell
you that the last year before t3 they
wanted they made us sit around to get
the information on fan fest well all of
us guys is gonna be in California that's
a foul daddy
I suggest everybody no or fill out a
fanfare that's just everybody only fan a
lot of fan fests go go go there because
it's about games you play games go to go
see PlayStation browse gonna be out
there you know people is gonna be out
there supporting this genre that we love
there's a lot of stuff for y'all to do
go see it go be out there mm-hmm now
that that that platform it still lacks
something a bite is like it's missing
food it's like somebody bringing you a
plate of food is a lot of vegetables
beef any opposed they're missing
something and I really believe is a set
up with the staff mmm the staff is the
Achilles heel to the whole production
and they can get away from the fakeness
of it feel fake pass the fakeness what
about two addicts question with him
about the announcements do you think
that phil was was getting kind of
breaking protocol just getting people
excited cuz normally they said they
wouldn't do nothing like that I think
that he talked about what he mentioned
was actually right around the corner I
think I think he's about to come out and
break that rule entirely mm I think I
think he realized that they never had
this kind of opportunity like you're
literally Sony's not gonna be there like
their biggest competitions not gonna be
there
mmm-hmm yeah obviously you know the
Tinder's doing good no I'm not trying to
I know people I know people are gonna be
like oh no the Tendo okay we all know
that endows doing good but they're in
their own lane let's be real like when
it comes to the to the the games that we
play the most Sony is their competition
and they've decided that they don't need
to be there this year so when the
antennas gonna be on the floor have a
presence yes I think when it comes to
what they're gonna be showing at yeah
obviously I think they will break
protocol it'll be a little bit and show
some stuff the refer that stuff that
they know is gonna come out what I think
a lot of what they're talking about is
the fact because Sony's
not there anybody who might have had a
presence on Sony's stage now they can
slide in and be like a man like you can
be on our stage as well like you know
agree so I think we'll see more of that
anybody who might have been presenting
something on during Sony's press
conference now has the opportunity to be
on Xbox and I think Phil understands
that he is a way to be put even more
content on his stage without necessarily
being forced to show his hand on the
Microsoft side too much so I think we
will get some broken protocol we will
see some stuff that's not ready for at
least another year after maybe two years
just a little teases and taste cuz I
think like I said before I've said this
in the past they have to be confident
enough and what they're bringing to the
table that they're not scared that
they're gonna have to cancel this game
and you know a year's time or whatever I
they have your your your development
process has to be better than that if
you want people to have confidence in
what you're trying to bring to the table
right cannot have that aura of fear
around you that any announcement you
make you may have to double back on yeah
I think the biggest thing we're gonna
see is we're like if like Brad said on
RDX we're about to get to the point
where every decision that you see is
Phil Spencer's and not just half of the
decisions you see cuz up until probably
about the beginning of last year you
were still seeing stuff that happening a
long time ago you know deals we just got
to crack down imagine like that and we
just got to crack down so it's a bit
specific sign what 2018 yeah I get that
we get to the elephant in the room we
talked to shadi
can we get to this cuz I'm with it means
shout out shout out the Fonz Fonz put
out a great video about how he felt
about it specifically how the ps5 took
on that same day sort of overshadowed
the SHA day and it overshadowed it in a
way besides what the shot I did to not
help its own cause right we the price of
water with all that stuff no I just
think that yeah the sade if you're
putting if you put that system out and
you're saying that that's a feeler to
see how people feel about an all-digital
console releasing that system at $260
with grief
older games that are already on game
passing and makes no sense you're
putting it in a position to lose what is
the point exactly
listen let's get to it one get on this
one here's the day it's like it's like
you say something like first off like
again what stick what's the expression
we use King like in a playoffs Knicks in
the first Indiana players playoffs Game
seven Patrick Ewing instead of dumping
the ball or getting the win the game
golf playing the role this was a lay out
lay like you got a digital-only system
goes head we come before come the
marketed teams head man yeah I'm tired
of you got that rescission is Phil's
dough that decision there's no mark me
that's not ran by Phil you know I think
you know I think there's a theory that's
going around somebody setting the dude
up the field type of dude either for a
kind of guy this reeks distinct if at
the end of a console generation it's
hard to find a reason to purchase a
console anyway when you know a new ones
probably coming out the next year how do
you not position this to fly off the
shelves how do you not say listen $200
with a year game pass go right you know
what it was that was nice but one 7995
has always been there number of that
sweet spot that's me right
the disrupt but apparently discovered it
of like this this is one of the very few
scenarios like people would like to
attack the market it seemed for
Microsoft a lot and I think this is one
of the few times they dropped the ball
because like especially what happened
with Superman eggs in the past why is it
decide system like this is like this
isn't the first time my name's been
thrown away
and I feel like to this point that they
should know and they should really
evaluate everything they do because they
know it can be turned around on but I'm
sorry I'm ready I'm ready like Oh at
them over the marketing of their games
and stuff like let's be real here they
haven't had nothing to market when it
comes to game wise so I don't really
blame them for not highlight and record
ok Kings saying like these are layups
these are given the player yeah this is
an all-digital system you supposed to be
cheaper than you know cheap-ass you got
the S out there with battlefield
whatever you know and here's the part I
should have done is they should have put
it it should have been 250 and they're
like it to the end of year it's gonna be
on sell for 200 or something to the year
game alright
I really think it III don't do a stupid
move right way they could have hit it
out the park from the jump right right
they're gonna get - III didn't over hit
you with - I'm gonna do a backpedal and
drop the price down right any dumbass
day one fool ya you know 250 was aquick
I don't understand I really don't get it
why you would do because don't you have
to drop the price and I know a lot of
people say now you don't have yes you do
like if you took out something that
costs money right on this system right
right and you say this was your D Talent
yeah right before daybreak where is the
4k blu-ray player right you remove
exactly exact you supposed to make this
thing sexy and attractive and less be
aggressive like put it out at the $200
you only give in old games with it
anyway they can't afford harassing three
who exactly why
Oh crack down give me crack down give me
four eyes before give me stated these
why don't you just give everyone six
months a game pattern even then you can
get away with 250 if you give you could
say like okay like you you put in that
250 out you put six months of game pass
you don't have to put the games no one
place on the Box you could put a halo 5
on the box you could put the Master
Chief collection in the box
you could literally have that box look
look like an infirmary right you can
announce the games that are coming to
game pass right you can now see whatever
like you can even use it as a platform
for what's coming next like you big ears
5 is coming handle any job why why they
need just debut game pass ultimate with
that exactly bring it and we talked
about this like a couple of weeks ago
like it makes perfect sense that this
game pass ultimate has been rumored is
it should launch at the same time and
then number two you know is the biggest
mystery even when we talked about it
before it had been rumored it hadn't
been out right but we know what else was
the biggest misstep even brass section
of the brass sands talked about this he
was very befuddled was remember maverick
this is maverick right this was supposed
to be where they had the program we have
you had the game the physical then you
could trade in and get to dick all of a
sudden our program has went mi a that no
one knows what happens in his program
now like no one could even says god no
one can find out what's happening and
that was supposed to be another selling
point with you if you did have the discs
and say hey boo Microsoft he trade in
get a different version that program of
it I'm just hoping cuz I feared of the
day you know they can only do so much
when it comes to the games like if
corporates not gonna approve that they
can't do nothing so great I'm all up in
like next-gen like they give them more
free rein to do what they want with the
marketing because you can't be
aggressive if you're AB one ant behind
your back you know like there's no
reason why that came out it's like if
you go on Amazon you can find you can
find it and they serve like on sale but
at the end of the day if you could go on
a website and find something even on
sell this works that's look that's
cheaper than something you're selling
right now
buddy anybody that has stock in their
stores at this point is selling it for
less than MSRP period whatever it is but
I don't like solve how to using that as
the out like the the new out now is like
it'll always be $50 cheaper but again
the messaging is confusing right just
bring the price down and then play that
little MSRP that make at the end of the
cycle when you have a PlayStation has
trouble selling consoles at this burner
right they know what's coming next so
why would you not place this in a
position to win sack especially when
you're using this as a testing bed for
the possible your car I'm three three
right price drop across the boards they
do a $50 slash and everybody well I get
that but at the end of the day if you're
gonna do that you might as well just
announced that before e3 so doesn't hurt
the launch of this one I think King is
right though I think you're trying to
catch the suckers who jump out early
right and then the late Ernie here to e
threes and the arm you know the Black
Friday wave then it's gonna be what it's
supposed to be okay I mean I would
probably do is they drop at 50 Eddie
they drop everything the extra the s and
the the side addition what a minute
and then at club skirt and then at black
Black Friday you can get a [ __ ] about 50
which is a good move but at the end of
the day it's like why did you start the
the sell for the air of the of the the
sad it's not even necessary it sucks so
bad you can of course hey I'm so sick
and tired of being out of every juggling
change the locks on these guys again one
has to know
the way this generation is playing from
this is how you portrayed videogames 2x
bone with the name rocks at I'm gonna
call it a shot baby
I'm gonna Kohli be shot a that's what
it's called after the mama name of the
shot is a shot either make any decisions
is not cognizant they're not they don't
have their finger on the pulse of gamers
gamers or going to take those acronyms
that's what's gonna have in that's life
in that let's look at the standpoint
what's happened in a week we go from you
know Xbox is getting a lot of a lot of
good good price from people say okay
ninja theory they made something
phenomenal like hell-blade so now
they're making a four player co-op four
player game
what's your a lot of people aren't gonna
like that because they wanted ninja
theory for that single game I know I
didn't and then you go from that to the
sad be that's 250 like any day was in
the PlayStation 5 doing Tony was in a
petty because Sony probably assume
you're he may be aggressive but this
$200 Xbox digital let's get some new
cycle out here and then they probably
look like I mean II had to do that ship
knows Microsoft messes up on just do
buzz words together sound chips and all
the madness and walked off the trailer
Sony is blown 8k knowing for sure
they're not doing okay but that doesn't
matter it's the day to read a narrative
out there and it worked
Slovo you gotta chill brothers they call
them it the shoddy isn't its move
operators man they go at Christmas go
ahead
the sweetest taboo flip it orders will
tell you they go ahead have $50 so
listen extra question do you respect
somebody that comes comes out and gives
the wait rounds or do you want somebody
knock out from the beginning like
beginning Mike Tyson their strategy nice
do the hell out from the jump
don't go in there trying to yeah before
oh we got two months out of it forget
about it is it these would be quick oh
all right
switch is it the news y'all back again
switch mini and switch bro
Pro rumors look like they are coming man
shout out to which one of these are fake
man pro-japanese publication nuts in the
chi can it make any decay as reported
you know saying that there's some new
details there's definitely a Nintendo
switch mini coming this one is gonna
focus on console portability it seemed
like this new model will support also
still support the docking is supposed to
definitely release this fall now rules
rumors on the pro have kind of got a
little murky in the sense that it's not
most likely coming out this year and
according to the publication Nintendo
still experimenting with a number of
different things for the device image
rendering operating system improvements
and that's supposed to be supposedly
next year but from what we understand
judging from the new info Nintendo
switch mini is gonna be dropping in full
of this year so I want to bring this to
the laws what do with topic theodora's
games at seven twenty thirty five phrase
yeah disrespect but oh yeah so with this
new information I'll bring it to the
table
realistically I want to start with King
and can occur there's no kicking attic
how they feel realistically what do you
want to stand out of the way this land
out early what do you want from the mini
and what do you realistically want from
the pro if it's gonna be next year
meaning from the mini all right that's
one alright so if there's a mini version
what I got upstairs you could take then
check that I want them to run it over
with a car no they took a look at what
happens to that stupid game remember to
fight you get rid of the joy cause play
right no you go you can play you can
play a convention away no you could both
you could play so probably like updated
to where you could play without there's
no cons but like no like I'm not about a
mini man it's already a mini all right
all right let me cover could I ask you
realistic haters this question gotta be
realistic now let's be real where's my
switches on the minis for little kids
oh hey gang let's be real realistically
King you do not play your minute your
switch portably at all your switches in
the dock right addict you play your
switch you take around but let's be
realistic is it the switch kind of big
for a portable delete you don't feel so
no you feel I mean what you a big dude
but I'm just saying like it Joe like
that in my hair it look like a cell
phone the normal size Yeah right
generally you know I'm saying at the end
of the day they want something a little
smaller so you don't be excitedly they
brought they still got the docking it's
small its portable you can actually rock
around you know I'm saying like oh
you're not excited no give me some more
power please bro give me the bro I'm
more excited with a pro okay this this
mini doesn't reach my radar it's not
even bomber so you know why I'm not
talking I'm gonna tell you what why
because they're gonna put that many at
the same price as this is to myself
right now you're Wyatt watch watch
you think it's gonna be three hundred
four minutes
you know it's funny it's gonna be 300
and they think we can bundle nothing
what they've melted so you think
Nintendo is that arrogant is so
cardboard you know if you look at the
release cadence foot for Nintendo's
consoles right whatever they usually
they'll release the base version and
then the next version of it improves on
it that's not what the minis doing the
minis dumbing it down right rid of
features they got most likely get rid of
no it's gonna be cheaper be with it it's
probably gonna be like 200 to 299 they
tell you why or not 99 buy it or not
so repair for the poor we look for those
little hand men you can get portability
yeah all those dudes complaining right
now stuck complaining just play with you
guys you could market that at 300 it has
features for the other are you by myself
don't me tell you why cuz that d-pad is
fraudulent that depending no d-pad many
you see
with the mini so now we are here
trolling you be feeling like something
if you want to playing with that you
stop that rise you'll be a bit you be
feeling a little do feel no type of
weight drops which I don't go away at
all I take it out I play it if they
ain't got it that's a business I don't
feel no way with the skin you are yo
when I like beautiful where's the
follower for you you don't play your
switch point oh I took my switch with me
when I was in Boston
yeah one time and I was really put in
that work addict you know what I'm
talking about
solve you know when I'm told that d-pad
is not a d-pad is separated segmented
buttons deeper do it snow we go get most
like I went I bought the Ori the $20
Orion I did that who's out here by an
8-bit dole they doing all these things
because a deep hat is fraudulent and I'm
a dude I want to play my mortal comes
anyone you're buying Mortal Kombat on
the switch he is ok sovereign you're the
new host surfer the host battle I'm so
sick and tired of this line this is not
the lie we won't let you hold you are
not going in this pool with six seven
hundred dollars of your box to go by
switch material you're not doing this
like I need the deep end sauce man Oh or
not having three switches stop there's a
rotary the sex is one gonna be for the
plane you're saying affordable job you
know
like right now you're trolling me I can
see if you say yo I'm gonna get a pearl
cuz that pro and pro might come with a
different D pad button right there
Minnie listen a cutback is a cutback
system is a cutback for full price
they're gonna take stuff away in
charging $300
I'll be like I can't agree with I'm not
getting that Minnie man cuz again they
killing features on it it's for the kids
it's try its finally trying to push
people away from the three TS
and I'm okay I'm okay with that actually
action in the backyard graveyard with
the Wii U let's get that out of here all
right here's the dip we go we Lolita
Media locus clearly this is a point of
contention about the V T anymore which
is scheduled to release this year now
the second question is to pearl which is
now they still experimenting II don't
know which way to go there's a lot of
confusion you know I'm saying but um we
do know it's coming most likely next
year so it's gonna be right on out on
time with your scarlet and the PS file
so what do we realistically expect from
the switch pro power some more
resolution a little bit more speed I
mean you saw some games that was at PAX
that I honestly thought that these games
is running on elevated system I really
didn't think that they were running on a
regular arm switch because these games
showed a level of form and polish that
was unhurt I mean really nice-looking
very fast games and I'm sorry if you
guys aren't in with ps4 Xbox he's down
with all pro in case you know that's
what I want to run hell-blade on it what
this thing looks like all the lighting
out all of it I was looking I was like
you know trying to get lore carnita to
pick up Final Fantasy 10 cuz it's like
one of my favorite Final Fantasies and
I've seen you're looking at this game
I'm like I look at the trailer for Final
Fantasy 10 I'm like yo
bad like it's like they took all the
color coming in hot
now I do think I'm gonna be in on the go
that's still good yeah it's ridiculous I
don't know why it's like it's on the ps4
you can pick up for $25 did you just say
give me what he's drinking exactly what
you got because we can water a protein
brother but yourself finish this up man
what do you think minion Pro way you
think pricing that you want yeah I think
the mini yeah I think the mini would be
too I honestly I would not be surprised
if they even drop down the resolution of
that screen more and made it smaller
made the screen smaller if they're
looking for true portability right the
true replacements is it for the 3ds the
screen will be smaller they may be
willing to drop down resolution a screen
because they're gonna be like it doesn't
matter that the screen is so small
it'll still be able to upscale fine to
the fact that that it's still a dockable
machine okay is it playing the division
that's all like no amigo gimmicky stuff
you see that rock that that big
oversized statue of I'm King has like
that method the axe is destroying that's
the mini that's a person right now mini
that mini if it comes out this year it's
winning Christmas we just know that we
could put me on that that's winning
Christmas Mary tell us coming here oh
you see if the mini comes out
if it comes out here is winning
Christmas and many is winning Christmas
okay they can win all the Christmases in
one it's going win it at 299 it's gonna
knock it out the park Rick
knock it out Rick 299 you guys are
looking really weird and pro like I said
is that - guys that is close to ps4 Xbox
baby yeah yeah base power base power nap
so we need approaches to run stand your
games okay standard games on is turned
on its head at the point this supposedly
this Pro comes out next year we're
talking about we're looking for it for
it to be comparable to seven year old
huh what it cost for a pro ps4 Pro so
you're paying three hundred and fifty
two for two dollars to have those have
an experience like the base x-box and PS
which all of you looking at a portable
system good but what about this tool i
mean it remember the rumors initially
was that xbox and these guys gonna play
but then the rumors kind of being put on
a home because all the functionality in
the system what a pro services that
whole marriage between Microsoft and
Nintendo if you act out anecdotal
bluetooth in the joint the opto we're
asking them to put bluetooth now they
gotta be able to upgrade they form fact
they got to update the innards in order
to have game pass rockin in that joint
if that's the eventual goal that's what
the rumors all I want for Christmas is
basic features so Sully
for MIT at the end of the day what if
solve is my softer Damas might be right
again man you're talking about getting
it comparable to seven-year-old hardware
at that point seven year old or we're
like this is not possible I'm looking at
the definition of broad and you guys
keep coming up like I honestly listen
I'm not gonna say it anymore y'all a
beat this to death play and you know you
wrong you just wanted to come back with
a bang that's alright we just walked in
the door you just want to make sure that
you close the show bang hey rube you've
done it my friend you had never really
done it with the 150 talk this guy over
here get it right switch mini hard it's
gonna burn straight throw it in so hot
is $2.99 for him and that other one over
there that's faux on it maybe 450 if
they go squeeze some extra bucks out of
your butt I'm telling you right now
y'all better be 450 just because of the
switch cars yeah you know what at it you
know what makes no sense this dude said
yo yeah it's a seven year hard wind
right now is like 15 years like you know
the pro gonna be the standard Xbox and
ps4 like okay that's gonna last for what
a year and the next colleges are out
like then we're back to square one where
they can't run anything neither right
and I think they would be a mistake but
cog mentioned that they didn't know what
they didn't know what their game plan
was with the pro yet right hmm meaning
they don't even know if it's putting
reportable which we're assuming it's a
switch it's in the line of switch and I
think it would be a mistake if it's not
I don't think they should make a regular
home console and I don't
yeah I don't think that at all but what
if this is the base home console off the
rails this is completely off the rails
about Nintendo here it's always off the
rails don't ever do anything normal they
gouge your pockets the 150 was a viable
option in yo-yo Hemisphere it's not
brother you know damn well is 299 you
can wish you won't you can pray you know
you gotta go no we fit we kill switch
into the cow I've got two consoles
dropping real quick let's get some
nostalgic feels for the oh jeez what's
going on with Neo Geo cab car that you
know people are taking a stance is this
across America going on right now arcade
machines fraud you guys you're paying
$300 for one game some cases you're
paying $300 for all they say is a deluxe
cabinet and has like three games in it
and they charging you a little extra to
build your own cabin first you got to
build your own cabinet you got to put us
together a little Raspberry Pi crap um
I'm happy Capcom is putting out a new
system as deduced stick six buttons on
each side mmm
and it's coming with 16 games 16 games
that were never released in the home
yeah scuze me like aliens vs. predator
which is really good game a lot of good
titles that's there but I'm also on the
same day that Sony was putting out fake
news real news that game it had that
system has our Wi-Fi so it has Wi-Fi
leaderboards yeah right so this actually
has some online capabilities you plug it
into the back of your TV and as you know
as a portable system
you could take you wherever you want to
go you can get you on your fight on with
your friends now Neo Geo SNK my favorite
company has stated they're putting out
two new systems all for the success of
the Neo jinny Neo Geo minion which they
made it Brad way yeah right they made a
ton of money off of these they decided
to put out a new system standalone home
systems and then connect up to your
television and then gonna have new games
on it but at the same time they
announced that there will be a new Metal
Slug title coming out brand new that
will watch with these systems my
question is now with the success of the
Sham one up series but do you think that
these going to be viable for the
nostalgic people that couldn't afford a
Neo Geo back in the days action but now
their affordable prices
not like that Nintendo many actually 150
shot out to the chat and all parents
summers they say and it looked nice but
they say and that price is too much with
just 16 games okay 150 dollars for 16
games but you would rather go and spend
three hundred and fifty dollars for one
game mmm so at what point in time does
that 250 look like gold and at 350 look
like feces in your sock addict are you
uh interested in any of these mini
system sir nope remember he got into
gaming when it was Gamecube just got one
question about the Neo Geo mmm does it
play the division oh maybe you could
play it as weak does not no interest
only to this Capcom thing looks
disgusting it's a big-ass Capcom lo walk
way it looks absolutely disgusting 6 No
my findings what's funny is they're like
you know how much money we made offer as
an equal to what else can we
they're like wicked sell some oh don't
go all of those games some of those
games came out and that beat him up
collection they just released captain
commando final fight oh those were in
there ready street fight versus Predator
alien pursue predators the one that
hasn't come to any other any other
platform right exactly so it's that it's
it's for that price and for that look
I'm not feeling it the Neo Geo stuff I'm
wondering what the heck that is I'm glad
as a new Metal Slug coming out but are
they really building what are these
consoles they're talking about to me
when it especially when they're being
number two and three three yeah it just
feels like it's another mini type thing
maybe not in that form factor but it's
just adding more games yeah you know
like I would that's a collection you
know these Jersey for me I understand
the sentiment I think for me it's just
like everybody catching their wave real
say like Genesis doing it then it sounds
crazy lay not accompany on so far great
everybody's trying to cash that Nintendo
way would be mini says I mad at them I'm
at a money you know saying Capcom me
NeoGeo made their money would that would
of enjoyed a coming on with to this is
for King like we know what this is the
arcade King right see we don't roller is
he this is all to his narrative about
the resurgence of all these hot games
but I love all those I love those games
as well I just did to me the way they're
being presented particularly the Capcom
thing I'm like oh man like I mean the
Neo Geo thing is cool I think I don't
think it'll cost as much as that Capcom
thing right no I'd be interested either
way they actually trying to make like a
real brand new console like I just be
interested to see what that is
but if it is just more of the nostalgia
of their titles like just making a
number two and number three with
different titles than the first one they
released maybe a different form factors
I know a lot of people weren't
necessarily too happy with the the mini
arcade thing you can't actually really
play on that right you can plug it into
a TV and a school um
so that's cool to me but the Capcom
thing only 16 games the fact that is
yeah it's on more parts and it's like
all those those real arcade parts great
I'm not feeling the big Capcom logo
that's it and and I'm not feeling the
amount of games kengo's wrap your topic
or you de 100 with their Neo Geo
definitely make sure we're talking about
this like I purchased the Neo Geo gold
system I got that up says it's a
portable system as well as is the home
system says I'm putting it downstairs
um you know I'm into the nostalgia stuff
I'm into the stuff that yeah there we
used to play I got the Nintendo or many
I got the Super NES or many um I want
them to make a GameCube mini just so
they can have little capsules of my past
I take it you know right there I want I
want the sega system so these things I
think is viable for us price-wise that's
where it comes in if the price wise it
comes in under $100 that's great I'm
down for that
you know cuz they little raspberry PI's
and a big disrespectful kognito with all
that level and recovery after his take
on the Capcom thing right now getting
flack because the the emulator they are
using on it to to run little words yeah
exactly it's an open-source emulator
than nobody supposed to make money off
so it's kind of funny that the dudes
that will probably put a
cease-and-desist out on it are actually
trying to make money off update they say
any reports that the oh yeah that it has
now been properly licensed and that they
have yeah some of the developers
currently involved the software they
just haven't been contacted but they're
trying to use that with permission I
guess what well the thing with that
final burn our mocha sauce they gave
them credit in the actual title like
their licensing it like currently but
the edik on that final burn is when you
use it in any form of capacity it's
supposed to be free and it's supposed to
be shareware
you can build on it but you have titled
the sauce right also and you have to
also make whatever you did alterations
to the software it's supposed to make
that free as well
right right no doubt this is what it is
King arcade King got his wish
he's getting his SNK you know I'm saying
gloriousness was them five hundred out
of cartridges he said I have no you
really think about it now that they can
give me all that stuff that's been like
three to four or five thousand dollars
on for a hundred dollars
yeah I want their I want my Sunday
experience that and I won't say this if
they do a turbo graphics joint I might
be interested like that was my way to I
like to express that was my joke anyway
let's get er we gotta get about here
this late alright pols coming back
alright now people this week with the
recent announcement reveal of the
initial playstation 5 specs by mark
Cerny which feature has you the most
excited about the next generation
PlayStation console the choices are a a
cake for that glorious resolution jump
be backward compatibility for the
amazing PlayStation 4 library C SSD for
the faster loading times or D I don't
care y'all for know a K when moja a guy
that is the question those are the
choices please write the I'll be vote
when it goes up on Twitter tomorrow
Lords of the round table
Thank You brothers I've missed this show
so bad I miss this man this this is this
is home this is a whole minute
regardless of what you go through this
is therapy to talk the gains the chat
everything was late you know a lot of
fun so yo make sure you hate to like to
Scrabble all that good stuff
Lord addict I know you got to get to
work where can the fine people find you
what is going on is he gonna find me
playing uh Chikara on twitch I know
someone in the conversation is gonna
make fun of how I said that but that's
fine we all have our little things I
don't know if I'll beat the last boss I
have
when I wanna beat the slice boss I'm
gonna install the kit smooth he
officially lost his challenge last night
[Music]
you lost the chance to win $1,000 made
more money
my mama Africa looking every day gone
day and it's been the most acid that eat
my food ten days of his misery so
shout-out to kid for giving me the joy
he put his thumb out there and anything
I don't care what nobody say he's got
his lane he is probably the most
entertaining streamer of them from
software tie games
hilarious what's funny is uh when he
when he quit the stream he was like I'm
done
and he was like I had to go through
there I want you to block everyone that
gave me this to remove me just because
we gave you the chance to what $1,000 I
was like you guys knew I couldn't win
this no doubt that's what we got going
Lord solved in your serpro I gotta go I
gotta go I kill you have going Lord
solve the usurper of the Iron Throne
hold it down for two weeks
let's go no it's a wicked fabulous on
you yeah I'm happy to crawl back into my
hole you can't go out there to power out
there in the world and you know the
world see you and you come back to the
damn show with the interview his face is
there it's 25,000 views you would think
like this guy looks like The Hunchback
of Notre Dame so he hiding his face like
he really just figured from some wild
accident when he was playing with Pumas
of the child but no this is not the case
sovereign is a handsome man and I can
say that because I'm comfortable in my
masculinity
he's a handsome man and he should
definitely have his hand place to be
depression or y'all came into the world
on me I know it doesn't work on the peer
pressure he is I've been around this man
forever
peer pressure doesn't fold them you guys
gonna have to pay for the face Twitter
low P and B accelerant on Xbox Live and
PSN hopefully beginning back to some
gaming this way I haven't touched
anything and damn near month
I can't wait how's the sentence they
said why he don't want you to that's
what it is Lord King with the triumphant
return king of statues arcade king
combat talk King we got all the kings
today what's going on sir do you see
that statue of the bad guys do you
really see that statue move back now I
know you're sitting here like Oh
King me bust early bro you put out the
de Bangor in ASDA Bangor that's
certified noble you ain't see nobody
right raizy
back to do that did it hit me up and I
got exclusive contract with him all his
new stuff to come out um you know at a
discounted rate because I will not put
anything up that I do not own or
purchase my own self alright now that
being said I have statues is still to be
unboxed that looks that to Shane that's
crazy
all right I got the statue this week is
an Avengers themed statue that Shaw want
to see you don't want to check out the
promo I like I keep telling you guys
follow us on the Facebook on community
or follow us on our Instagram make sure
that you follow us on Twitter because
what you get on the YouTube channel is
not the same thing that you get at these
other channels because when I put it up
I can't put out certain music because
its copyright infringement that YouTube
will allow me to post I work very hard
on these promos just be you guys I'll or
cog needle doesn't want me to give it to
you yeah I'm giving out too much we
stuff and I need to stop yeah they gotta
click the video you got to start with
tweeting
clicking the video shot the cat daddy
said people make Illuminati sacrifices
for a statute like that King right this
is facts I feel you and if you go to the
Instagram you can actually see the
pictures me no ad it was like that rock
that he's standing up those are dead
bodies that he's standing on he's
standing on a ton of bodies and if you
actually go to the Instagram you here
I'll put drowning pool that the bodies
hit the floor while I was playing in
that spinning I mean I put in our work
so you got combat talk with the King
coming next week and I'm still trying to
get the arcade King to you guys I try
not to show you too much because there's
a ton of stuff there and it's gonna be
super interactive I want you guys to ask
me questions and give me suggestions for
games that you want me to play and I'm
not gonna be crying and screaming like
kids move because if it's frustrated I'm
turning it off no you're not gonna make
a meme out of me dude out as we got
that's what it is and of course lord
cocky no head of realm was lit everybody
in check please like subscribe hit that
retweet y'all if that retweet y'all put
this out there and we're given good
times out in the room absolute pleasure
Lords of gaming dotnet for your gaming
news we shout out to dizzy and all the
fantastic writers more content coming
more secret announcements coming
you already know stream team so now
they'll l-boogie MJ's a boss old-school
style back in the building the lipo we
miss you man I know you're working the
lobby we miss you is getting packed
popping and shot everybody like I said
that came through fantastic return king
of statues is up there right now please
I get our combat stalkers up there the
last word with Yvonne chest is up there
it was a fantastic discussion me and my
brother going at it about the future of
- d3 division and anthem please check
that out everybody enjoy your Sunday
Happy Easter
we're gonna see y'all next week man
peace